this is the awful truth
there's always someone in the family
that's pushing it
this lady does not deserve
to be taken advantage of especially
at your age with your own grandchild
yeah
my grandma is having to sue them i'm
testifying against them
nobody's talking they're one floor below
right now i get afraid to go on the
elevator
it's sad that it had to devolve to this
it's like a soap opera it's a very sad
thing
it's a family feud a family view
here's a family that on paper you would
think has the wealth that
so many people seek yet at the end of
the day it
seemed to sort of rip everybody apart
[Music]
my name is tom schoenberg i'm a senior
reporter here at bloomberg news cover
financial enforcement
i was approached by someone close to the
schottenstein family
and asked whether or not i would be
interested in
writing about beverly schottenstein and
this case that she had
against jp morgan and it was immediately
clear that
there was a great story here to be told
so i started just you know assembling
all sorts of documents that the family
made available to me that included
a diary that beverly had begun writing
when she started
having suspicions about what was
actually going on with her money
beverly obtained her wealth from the
schottenstein kind of retail empire
that has at times included big lots
value city
american eagle outfitters dsw shoes
beverly's husband died and at which
point they sold off their portion of the
company
bringing them an enormous amount of
wealth in around 1990.
estimates of her wealth were around 90
million dollars
she for many years had that pool of
money being managed by outside advisors
her grandsons in the late 2000s had both
graduated and were becoming financial
advisors she
gave them a little bit to work with and
over time
her grandson evan became the trustee of
her entire estate
managing sort of family money is not a
conflict
in fact some ways in wealth management
it's kind of how you get your start it's
kind of the seed
that you need to sort of get going in
the business but
beverly started having suspicions that
something was wrong
probably in around 2016.
well there were suspicious things
but taken separately without everyone
talking about their own
experiences it was hard to really put it
together
she had written a check to her
caretaker dawn that bounced so she
went down to her local chase branch to
sort of find out what was going on
she wasn't getting paper statements in
the mail so she asked them to print out
a number of her statements
having to do with her checking account
and her credit card account
so we went to the bank and asked for the
statements
and she got a whole year and going
through
all of them page by page by page
and it was there she saw all sorts of
charges that she said
she didn't authorize or didn't know
about i was becoming
very very suspicious i would start to
look in the money part
and that's what bothered me more when i
saw that
money was going and i was not a big
spender
around the same time dawn she starts
noticing beverly's son
who lived in the condominium below her
came up with evan
with a shredder and started grabbing
papers
in her office area including some with
jp morgan letterhead
and just sat started sitting at the
kitchen table just shredding documents
over and over yeah they came in one
morning
they used to do it at the back through
the back door
and they brought this shredder inside
and then they
went in the drawers in the office and
took out all the
papers and they start to doing it i was
very suspicious because i know
you don't go around and getting
destroying papers
beverly said that they had done this
many times before
that's when she said to me you know dawn
i'm going to write my feelings
in this black book diary and is a diary
and she started writing each day she
would write
a little at a time
around the holidays of 2018 the package
had arrived a fedex package and in it
were materials about a venture capital
fund
based on the cayman islands dawn and
some other family members take a look at
this
and they see that beverly is signed up
for this fund to the tune of 5 million
over the course of several years and
that was really the beginning of it
um that was sort of the tip of the
iceberg when it became
obvious that something was going on that
my grandmother really wasn't aware of
this fun
you know beverly started to panic she
was got really upset and called
you know jp morgan's headquarters in new
york and asked for jamie dimon
she said she was told someone would call
her back um
but she says that that never happened
she wrote a letter
to evan and avi and in there she she
laid out
a number of things that were concerning
her unauthorized trading
the checking account she had about a
million dollars worth of jewelry
in a safe deposit box and that her son
bobby had the key to that box
and that that jewelry had gone missing
all this was kind of packaged in this
you know five-page handwritten amendment
to a will and trust
there's such an evolving narrative about
why the jewelry was taken the only truth
we really know is that the jewelry is
gone
but why it happened there have been a
lot of different stories
you just don't take your mother's uh
wonderful things and hand it out and
they email that note to jp
morgan to seize all activity on her
account
and it ended up setting off a firestorm
after that
as soon as they got this email that
there was a seasoned assist and that she
wanted to send her money
uh and change brokerage firms they were
actually
vacationing one floor below downstairs
they're there right now
the next day beverly's in her her place
the granddaughter's still in in her
place visiting
dawn is there and up comes
bobby kind of barging through the door
and he's screaming about
what was sent to the jp morgan they're
now investigating them
and he's furious takes his mother and
sort of
puts her into a chair gets pen and paper
and she says physically forced
her to write a retraction letter they
were
pushing me around it was a scary time i
was really afraid too
i had to take her to the doctor and she
did an x-ray
because she was in so much pain the
locks had to be changed the phone number
had to be changed
i really thought we were going to have
to hire guards to be outside just for
protection
oh it was terrible horrible scene
[Music]
beverly brought her case before the
financial industry regulatory
authorities usually
known as finra it took several months of
hearings
she sees all sorts of transactions
that's going on
hundreds of them that she claims that
she never knew about
never authorized but yet were logged in
jp morgan's files as having been direct
requests from her
that included the sale of a large amount
of apple stock
worth several million dollars as well as
all her stock and big lots
you know over the course of their time
with jp morgan
evan and avi were making all sorts of
trading on her account
that was generating millions of dollars
in commissions for themselves in the
bank
yet she was not sort of getting any of
the type of gains
that you would expect sort of an 80
million dollar account in a bullish
market to be able to get
they issued a ruling entirely in her
favor finding that
her grandsons as well as jp morgan they
were liable for
violating their fiduciary duty
misrepresenting themselves
and they also found that the bank and
her grandson
evan reliable for elder abuse
evan and avi they were fired from jp
morgan they
issued an award of about 19 million
dollars
i reached out for comment and jp morgan
emphasized that
evan and avi were no longer with the
firm and that
their actions do not represent the sort
of values of the
of the bank i reached out to evan and
avi heard back from their lawyer
saying that you know they disagree with
you know the law and the facts that
finra kind of used to decide the case
against them and are seeing if they can
have it withdrawn
her son bobby wrote her a letter said
his sons weren't criminals
and he also admits to taking her jewelry
and he says he needed it to pay off some
bad business debts he had
they never once came up to say i'm sorry
if there had been an apology and some
acceptance and and and asking for
forgiveness uh from my grandmother i
don't think we'd be in the position that
we are
now since the piece came out we've you
know we've received
dozens of messages from people uh many
of whom are telling their own
sort of personal tales of uh you know
kind of financial advisors gone bad
or family members who got control
of an estate and abused
you know those within seems that it's
it's really resonated with a lot of
people i
keep you know hearing a lot of feedback
about beverly and how
you know a lot of people feel she did
the right thing you're never too old to
stand up for yourself
and try to write an injustice she was
adamant that she wanted to stand up for
herself but at the end of the day
they did wrong it's a painful life
lesson
you know beverly taught them that you
don't mess with grandma
[Music]
you